this is a production of Cornell
University so today my topic is called
everything's coming up D is talking
about how not just I but a bunch of
other people in extension are starting
to create a system to support the Cut
Flower industry in New York city so how
many do you have any grower Cut Flower
Growers I can't okay so how many people
have flot flowers at a farmers
market that's a good start how many how
a flower
CSA well there's at least three that I
know of which one are you in sorry I
which one are you and they have posies
okay well I used to in Seattle okay and
so they have them there as well yeah so
I'm also playing how about roadside
stands and how about
dck okay and how about the vents so this
picture is to show that flowers either
even just growing fields of sunflowers
is a big deal for weddings now and
flowers getting your flowers look
flowers for weddings is a big deal too
so we're starting to see if you've done
any of those things you've seen that
there's a lot of cut flowers available
that didn't used to be there used used
to be Flor and maybe grocery stores but
we're making progress and where they're
getting sold so all right now let's
see so in New York state the wholesale
value of cupf flower sales increased one
and a half times between 2020 to 2021
that's pretty dramatic and now that's
only looking at operations of 100,000 or
more and I will guarantee you that we
have a lot of small cutf Flower Farms
that are not up at 100,000 in terms of
what they're bringing in a year so all
the numbers that I can find are
definitely going to be
underestimates if you look at the 2019
censes it said there are 122 operations
with it with two 2.7 million in sales if
you look at the association of specially
Cut Flower Growers that a lot of Growers
are members but not all you can find
about 130 in New York um so there's at
least that many let's say one of the
questions if you want to work with them
is how do you find them and what do they
need so just looking at what's been done
so far oh soor this is from one of the
cup flow Growers um actually had on
their website New York Flower Farms it's
called um so this is looking at the
major distribution methods for the ones
that we're looking at we have a lot that
are do selling to the individual
consumer so so that could be a CSA or
farmers market or roadside stand there
are some that are selling direct to
florists so you can sometimes get local
flowers at your florist and there are
some that are wholesaling and maybe
often in combination with selling direct
and possibly with selling to to Flores
one of the things that's amazing when
you talk to cut flower Growers is how
many different things they're doing to
sell their flowers and often they cycle
through a
variety of different sorry something
just happened over there they cycle
through a variety of of different uh
Marketing Systems to find out the one
that works best for them with their
production how big they want to be and
so forth uh one of the things that I
will say about cupflower Growers is they
tend to be pretty entrepreneurial and
I'm not sure whether that's by necessity
or just that's the people that that
start out trying to do cut flowers uh so
the floriculture industry is definitely
paying attention you can find lots of
articles about growing cut flowers in
the trade journals um Growers aren't
waiting for us to to get information to
them um so they're starting this is a
Facebook page for Central New York
flower Growers or Upstate New York
flower Growers where there's a lot of
conversation back and forth about not
just what's for sale or price is or how
to sale or does somebody have something
but P management information and some
other production information as
well and now you can become grown in New
York state grown and certified for cut
flowers and not all of those crops came
in at the same time so this is a more
recent one I haven't I would like to to
find out how many are on this list but I
haven't figured out how to do that
yet so working with cutf flower growers
in New York state is not completely new
um anyone who's been in this department
for a while knows that but if you look
at Cooperative Extension they've been
doing some um programming mostly uh on a
usually on a one-off basis often very
Regional and it may depend on if they
have Growers asking them questions or if
they have some background information so
Russ welser for example in Ontario
County grew pies so he had background
information so he knew the Cut Flower
Growers and he did some programming for
them we only have about five counties in
the state that actually have Educators
who have H commercial horiculture as
their specific stated responsibility but
that doesn't mean those are the only
extension Educators who are doing things
like this they all do things sort of its
duties as assigned or as you get
questions does does commercial
horiculture be horiculture or does it
mean it means not FL related no it means
cut flour could be uh could be
floriculture Greenhouse Flor culture
Christmas trees any of those things but
it's not um consumer Horticulture which
is Master Gardeners and those not apples
and vegetables tends not to be fruit or
vegetables okay so it's kind of depends
though floral culture more so kind of
yeah I mean if you can consider a
Christmas tree a floriculture crop and
nursery and other things so so yes thank
you that's a great question uh and so
then there has been some occasional
Statewide programming at the Empire
State producers Expo it's been done a
couple of times but nothing too
consistent now Dr wean who was here and
did a picked up also picked up cut
flowers I don't think anyone told him to
I think he just picked it up as a a
potential um population to work with and
did great research on cultiv our
evaluation cultural practices High
tunnel production and you can still find
his research which is all archive down
the high tunnels bum page um the one
thing about doing um cultivar evaluation
is of course cultivars keep changing so
while that information is great it may
not have the newest cultivars but other
things the prep the production
information is all Val valuable
still and then we have related research
so both Bill and Neil have done things
that relate to cut flowers um Bill we're
getting to got another I'm trying to
sign up another place for to you you to
use your bulb machine um and so it it is
and bulbs are becoming one of the major
cut flowers that we're seeing um also
with some winter
production and then there's people that
are doing Pest Management and
ornamentals so Dan gilrain Marjorie
dodre both on Long Island John Sanderson
here on campus and Andy senac down on
Long Island both Andy and John have sort
of retired but luckily they'll still
answer when we ask them questions and
appear for things so um that's a good
thing because we're starting to run out
of people to ask questions
unfortunately and then back in 2017 Lily
Calderwood was the extension educator
for the Capital Area extension team and
she had so many calls on cut flowers
that she decided to put together an
annual cutf flower conference so that
conference has been running since 2017
it's the longest running cutf flower
conference that we have in the state and
it's actually managed to go through
three Educators so Lily started it then
Lindsey Christensen carried it on and
Jing Jing in is doing it and that's a
regional program of five counties but
they'll but it but the the conference is
open to anyone it's it's gone online in
the last few years um which means it can
reach some additional people than it did
before and then small farms has an
online Cut Flower production class that
they started in 2021 I co-teach it with
Hannah uh Hannah vpy who runs foxy Flora
around um Trumansburg and so s in three
years we're in the middle of I'm
teaching the fourth one tonight um we've
had 235 students and that's not just New
York state that's International but
that's a good goodly number coming in
through just that one point just through
the small farms so they have good
advertising um but still it's a good
number coming in and we have people that
wish we would make an advanced level of
it also haven't done that yet um so we
do get it's advertised to be sort of
zero to three years in cut flowers um we
get some people who've had more um and
it's but because they're all a different
lels it's an interesting method of
teaching where you're trying to not bore
the ones who know stuff and keep the
ones who are just getting started from
having their heads blow up um so it is
really information overload because
we're only doing it in six one and a
half hour sessions and trying to cover
all of of pest of not just Pest
Management but all of Cut Flower
production so um for my observation of
the people that are coming to that class
and also going to other events um they
get into the business Cut Flower Growers
get into the business from the widest
variety of backgrounds you can imagine
we've got Bankers we've got tech tech
people we've got people who are growing
some other kind of crop maybe vegetables
or dairy farms where they're adding cut
flowers to their production people who
have no concept of how to grow anything
because they've not really done it
before and people who have lots of
experience and it doesn't mean that any
of those people can't be successful
because we find people from all of those
starting points who arecurrently
succcessful in the state um and so
that's kind of a fun group to work with
because they bring different things to
the to the mix and one of the things
we're always trying to do in something
like this class is they have them talk
to each other so that if you got
information and you may well have more
information than I have then let's you
know let's share it let's make sure that
everybody gets it and has a chance to to
share
that so this is actually a meme that um
Amara Dunn made up for us when we were
establishing the habitat for beneficial
insects but I have a feeling it's also
true for Cut Flower Growers it looks
like they're beautiful flow flowers all
you have to do is put seeds in the
ground and you have beautiful flowers
but you always forget that there's
weeding and there's whether your soils
doing what it's supposed to do and what
insects come in so that's often true
that they start out thinking okay this
is going to be easy I saw cut flowers at
the farmers market and I've grown a few
cut flowers in my yard and so production
is going to be just like that it's not
always but
sometimes so just based on that that's
sort of the the past history of what's
been going on uh in New York state with
produ with information for Cut Flower BS
but then starting in 2021 I got a call
from Dana Havis who was in courland CCE
courland Cornell community community
extension sorry CCE is I can't put
Courtland and community in there is the
Cornell um Cooperative Extension CCE
well I'll probably say CCE a bunch of
times but anyway so um out of courland
and she was getting so many questions
she was actually a fiber person that's
her background was in fiber um but she
Saidi getting so many questions and
before Lindsay Christensen left the
Capital District she told everybody
apparently if you have any questions on
cut flowers call Betsy even though Betsy
didn't know anything about cut flowers
but was interested um so we came up with
sort of a mission of what we'd like to
do what what the issue is the fact that
there's not much background for Cut
Flower growers in the state and could we
put something together that would help
them so we actually did we based on a
list serve that we have um we'll pop up
later we actually did some some
questions on grower needs and educator
needs and the educator needs kind of
look like we need everything we don't
have enough to do for anything we need
the industry we need speakers we need
programming we need all of it and The
Growers come across I need almost all of
it as well weed weed management how to
plant schedules how to price things is a
huge uh aspect how to use high tunnels
um what and then soil fertility so
there's a lot of places that information
could go in and also a lot of people who
are looking for information to help fill
those
gaps so this is sort of the initial
group uh that started talking so Sharon
Bachman is in Erie County uh Caroline is
in Yates county I believe Russ weler is
in Ontario County jingjing is for the
Capital District Carla crims in Delaware
and Lindsay Paso is in um
don't remember one of the northeastern
counties and so actually L both Lindsay
and Russ have grown cut flowers so they
come in with some background information
which is helpful but most of the other
people are just getting questions and so
are interested and trying to put
something together that works to help
support them uh in in the questions
they're getting and actually this group
has now created a cutf flower program
work team which makes sense if you're a
faculty member maybe and probably
doesn't make sense at all if if you're
if you're a student program work teams
are groupings of faculty and extension
faculty um who are interested in a
particular topic so this is now sort of
just gives it a certain amount of
formality for the
University so the first thing that that
we did Dana and I was put together this
list serve and just sort of send out
information who's interested I could do
it through the class a little bit um
this is an old picture but it does show
you at least that we have have people on
the list serve from all around the state
as well as outside of the state and the
biggest point for having a list serve is
how do we find and connect Growers and
Educators that's what we're looking for
and it is an
interesting system in that it is
definitely not hi we know what's going
on and we're here to tell you what how
to do things it is much more a we're
looking for help can you help us do what
needs to be done so that we can get this
information out to a broader range of
Growers so anyone can post on it um it's
not it's not wildly used at the moment
but it does get used somewhat probably
needs some organization um and every
once in a while if I'm working if I'm
doing what I should be I'll post a
question but I usually can get some
responses back um which is nice to know
that people are actually
reading and then we also created a web
page which is at blogs. cornell.edu
cutflowers and so uh that's another
place of gathering information and
posting it in one place so people can
find things
and then again we this should be
something where we're getting more
two-way information but it it's it's
getting but it's not there
yet um but then looking at the just the
programming that's going on based on the
fact that there are people that were
interested um it's definitely expanding
so this is a a riskmanagement for cutf
flower Growers grant that Carla Crim got
and she put on um a free series of
webinars in 2022 and 2023 looking at
risk but risk in a broad sense so you
can see there's IPM there's crop
planting there's climate smart F farming
there's uh season extension all sorts of
topics that were in her series and well
this is just an example of she also had
not just Specialists talking about
things but Growers so this is Fran
Parish who her her operation is over in
Western New York and she does an
excellent job at putting on
presentations and Gathering informations
from the point of view of a grower which
is always nice to have it's one thing
for me to talk about IPM but I'm not
trying to make money doing it so having
a Grower's persective on it is also
nice and then that's difficult to read
in the back I'm sure but it's just a
list of the different speakers that they
had in the Capital District cupflower
conference for 2023 it was online then
it's also going to be online in 2024 I
think it's probably going to stay online
forever but again quite a range of
topics and bringing in both Growers and
uh faculty from uh Cornell and other
places as well there's somebody from the
University of
Utah they did uh they did the first uh
Cut Flower session at the Catskill Regal
Regional a conference and they're going
to do that again in 2024 again mixing uh
speakers from a a variety of different
places and then Long Island also added a
cut flower session to their egg Forum so
it's definitely popping up in a lot more
places we're seeing a lot more
programming it may or may not be very
organized compared from one to the next
but at least it's showing up so that the
Cut Flower Growers have something to go
and listen
to um this was a called A Cut Flower
intensive at bird song Farm CCE Delaware
has a um an association with this farm
and they actually put in cutf flower
beds to use for demonstrations and kind
of as U Community Gardens and so they
had speakers and then had people they
picked flowers for people and they had
them do sort of an Iron Chef U um
arrange ment competition they were make
this one was on the summer barbecue so
they it was amazing to see what people
did There's peppers in there there's
what they did in terms of creating
Arrangements on that
topic and I think they enjoyed doing
that I didn't I didn't get my fingers in
that one we're also looking at getting
some more on Farm programming of growers
in my estimation love hearing other
Growers talk about what they're doing
and it's a good way to get connections
and again um this was some soil Health
programming that Jing Jing Yin put on
she's on the far right and it's another
place you can see and it's hard maybe
tell something the picture but the
audience in cutf flower Growers tends to
be younger than the other audiences that
I serve in terms of ornamental
production um they tend to be more
female and they have they come in ready
to roll and with lots of great ideas and
that's kind of fun to go and talk to
them because and they'll correct you if
they think you're wrong which is also
good
so we're looking at doing some
additional getting some funding to help
support some of this so uh in the
Capital District they wrote the
Northeast Extension risk management
education fund Grant on cutf flower
pricing because pricing is a huge huge
issue um Jing Jing wrote one for FL Farm
viability on cover crops and field and
high tunnel for Cut Flower production
and we've put in an application for a
CCE intern this more this for this
summer um working in cut flowers in CCE
so I'm talking really fast and we'll see
where we go here so one of the questions
that I have for you is like why should
you care so I can see opportunities for
on Farm research because these Growers
are looking for information and help and
they're pretty willing to to let faculty
come on their farms and and work on them
I see opposition I see potential for
positions for students either as Growers
or in extension and knowing more about
cut flowers but but I want to know what
potential you
see for in the horiculture section for
cut
flows where I get to stare at all of you
instead of you staring at me does
anybody have any ideas does anybody
online have any
ideas they're shy shy is everyone using
landscape fabric Betsy I'm curious so
it's interesting so because Brian's a
weed scientist he would ask a weed
science word a question so some people
do use landscape fabric and plant in
hole through holes in the landscape
fabric and for some of the things I've
seen dalas on it for sure I've seen pies
on it PES tend to stay there longer and
some people don't like it because you
get dirt on top of it and then you get
weeds on top of it and so they're using
all sorts of different things for weed
management I have not yet heard of too
many people complaining about um
herbicide resistant weeds in their
operations but it may just be that they
haven't figured out that that's really
happening yet um so there's been there
was a big debate in on one of the one of
the discussions we had was on do you use
I also say just to throw in to kind of
go with this conversation that a lot of
The Growers that I talk to either want
to be organic or are organic sometimes
wanting to be organic may or may not
mean that they actually know what it
means to be certified organic but they
would like to not use pesticides
including herbicides and they would like
to use something else so when you start
talking about just putting down uh
plastic mulch the question comes up
should you use biodegradable or
degradable plastic mulch and most of the
Growers who tried it said no because
what you end up with is a lot of pieces
of plastic you can actually remove the
non-biodegradable stuff much more easily
than the biodegradable stuff but that's
one of the things that seems to have
popped up multiple times in terms of
weed
management so I know why I'm interested
so I'll tell you why I'm interested and
why I think there's potential for this
so I just in terms of the IPM
programming I read this is my fifth
presentation this year on cut flowers so
there's obviously interest and that's
not counting the class and there's
obviously people that are trying to get
that programming going it also looks to
me like um as I said the interest is in
organic or no or low pesticide inputs um
the understanding of Pest Management
varies dramatically and I don't see
through the association and other things
I don't see very much Pest management
information out there so it seems like
to me it's a perfect place for me to be
that that there's a need there's uh I
that's where my seep learning herf comes
in because I don't necessarily know the
answers but that there's that there's
someone who looking for the information
and are and they're willing to work in
two ways with me which I enjoy um so
what's different about Pest Management
for cut flowers the crop diversity is
immense between species and cultivars um
It's a combination of field and high
tunnel often they have sequential
planning and long Harvest periods which
I don't see and things like bedding
plants in the greenhouse production for
example um the aesthetic level means
because you're selling both the flowers
and the leaves often that the threshold
pest thresholds are really low so they
need good Pest Management um and can't
tolerate very much uh damage so how many
crops other crops do you know where they
would actually go B out and bag every
flower Bud that they're going to sell
which they do with dalas for a tarnish
plant bun damage so and interestingly
when the grower said oh yeah it's not
that not that big a problem I don't know
it just seems like it would take an
inordinate amount of time and it's also
a very high value crop so all those
things work together to mean that Pest
management information is really
essential in my mind um and sort of fun
to to learn about how to
do uh so just in looking at the kinds of
projects that I'm looking at um there's
Pest Management is strategic plan
funding from the Northeast IPM Center um
looking at identifying the major insect
and disease pests and what the
management methods current are currently
are so that you can use that information
to determine what to do next what
research could be done next and then um
some work looking at both augmentative
and conservation biocontrol and and cut
flower beds conservation biocontrol
means using what's already there and
encouraging it augmentative really means
going out and adding it so you're buying
commercial sources um we don't that's
very there's very little information on
that the conservation one there's more
information on but it's very difficult
to me to measure and so figuring out how
to measure it is another
piece all right I think that's the end
of M and I maybe even came in sort of on
time or maybe too short but whatever
it's it's
lovely yes you have a question lots of
lots of questions I'm sure um how do so
so most of the cup flowers that
Americans consume come from Colombian
Ecuador and places that have a favorable
climate year round and probably cheaper
labor and then airplane transportation
to get you money to me um so how do New
York Cut Flower Growers differentiate
themselves from those types of products
sometimes it's the crops they're growing
so ronculus is a big thing for spring
and it's interesting I was talking to a
grower that's in uh Clifton Springs
Phelps area and she said well she's not
emphasizing this summer flowers anymore
she's really pushing ranunculus and
she's got high tunnels um because at at
a farmers's market which is where she
sells and also through a CSA she said
people are dying for color in the spring
so you can sell a lot of verulus which
are
expensive and and so there's that piece
of differentiating by by crop by some
things that just don't ship well um
there's you know there's enough of a
local interest in local food and local
flowers and local everything that that
helps so they can promote themselves as
local um it is you know it's it's an
expensive product and it's one that's
considered maybe a luxury by some people
and so that does perhaps limit the
potential sales through just looking at
the the whole population but um and so
sometimes it's also the variety of
things that you can get but I do think
there's a certain amount of it it's like
it's nice to go to a farmers's market
and walk out with a bunch of Flowers in
Your Hands and so I think there's some
of that I think is just people's
interest in that whole um local
purchasing and and going and just doing
the whole sort of almost Agri tourism of
of a local of local
production
yepop these resources are there many
things you can pull from like
established resources in neighboring
states or are there not robust markets
in neor States so much more so than
that's a great question and one of the
things that the original this original
talk went to be giving it in
Pennsylvania because they're trying to
do the same thing so it's not that there
are none and there are some states that
have a lot California has quite a lot um
and and some states have more than most
states have more than we do but um
between actually talking to not falling
over the table and not standing with a
light in my but so we can find some but
there's doesn't seem to be like here's a
one here's one good place to go find
this and then some things are regionally
different so if you're talking about
producing ronculus in in New York it's
different than if you're talking about
producing ronculus in California and so
we need some of that as well updating
things to make them um relate
here y got a question might jve with one
that's showing up in the chat as well um
any research on the possibility of using
Cut Flower crops searching as potential
beneficial inet habitat that you could
crop along with other crops and Farms
maybe would want to give up space to
beneficial habitat labor but if you
break even make little money
on the two go together so I've actually
been working on installing beneficial
habitat that's not cut flowers
necessarily in and we've got a plot in
Christmas trees at the moment to see if
you can get the benefits of that
beneficial habitat on the insect pests
in the Christmas trees and you're right
that takes up land and so it's a little
bit hard to do that and I agree that if
you could do it and cut it and sell it
um then then you've got a then you've
got an advantage where it's not just
wasted land it's also additional labor
and some of these crops are pretty high
labor some things that people do are
like start with sunflowers because you
can seed in a row of sunflowers they're
pretty low maintenance in terms of of
getting them where you want them they're
not the highest value but people like
them uh and and they'll still give you
some of those those environmental
benefits of bringing in beneficials um
and so potentially then also seeing but
then the question is can you measure the
effect of those beneficials on your
other crop is a hard piece but um you
know it yes it definitely can be done
and the thing is always going to be
balancing you know if you're taking time
away from your main crop you need
something that's relatively low labor
and relatively high value per unit area
just to to break
did I cover the one that they
asked yeah so that kind of covers that
concept of co-cropping and there are
people that are starting who have been
growing vegetables are starting to put
cut flowers in especially if they mark
it in the same ways it's it's a fairly
obvious connection I think sorry Bill so
a perfect example not of that but of
co-cropping I guess this the ball
planter and planting you pick sorts of
things like
daffodils in turf grass there's no
weeding there there's no problem and and
I I think it's finally starting to catch
on because there there's a importer here
in New York who brought in six machines
this fall wow and I know I I know they
sold three of them so far so and it's an
interesting thing because finally
starting to to come along upic is like
one of the things where you'd have to be
careful that people don't go in and
trash your plants when they're doing
upic but with tulips you actually want
them to pull the bulbs out they can pull
the whole bulb out so if they take the
plant and and they don't actually cut it
they pull the whole bulb out that's
actually a good thing because tulips are
grown as an annual for cut flowers
definitely maybe even daffodils less so
but well yeah they would they optimally
they would be perennials but but they
tend not to give you as big flowers the
second generation the second year round
and so forth sometimes anyway but the
way that people feel about bulbs they
often plant them as annuals yep
yep was interesting to hear about how um
the industry is growing over New York
State and how people are coming in from
a variety of different backgrounds um I
was wondering did you get a feel for uh
like why industry has been growing so
much and with people coming in from so
different backgrounds are they all
coming in for the same reasons when you
talk to these people well what do you
find about why they're so interested in
flowers one of the things is they're
like oh I'm so sick of a desk job I've
heard that many many times and um so
again it kind of goes to Neil's question
of like so you can buy flowers the
grocery store you can buy flowers at a
florist why should you start growing
your own because of this interest in
local and because I think people go to
farmers markets and see Road SCI stands
and hear about you and csas and upix
they're like well I could do that and so
it's it is but it is interesting I don't
know another industry where they come
from like everywhere and you know just
the concept of I don't want to work on a
desk anymore I want to be out in the
dirt which I appreciate but it's like
okay but it's kind of like it doesn't
and also maybe the thing with pet
flowers is you can start kind of small
and just grow a few rows of things and
sell them at a roadside stand without
too much infrastructure and therefore
you can kind of get into it that way
it's very interesting to see how people
adapt too once they get in they think
they're going to do these things and
they end up doing those things sometimes
too someone else had a question yep yeah
so I'm got to stud cup flowers and I'm
really interested in the local cut FL um
production market so I was just
wondering if you think that there might
need opportunities for careers extens I
think so because there looks like a huge
gap so yes I do think so um it is you
know one of the
things because one I think one of the
pieces that needs to fit in there is
identifying the number of growers in any
given area as I said with Lily
Calderwood she came in to do she was
doing floor culture but not cut flowers
but there were so many questions that
she started adding that I think if we
actually looked at the industry and
started documenting where these Cut
Flower Growers are there would be you
know it would be worthwhile for an
extension office to say we need somebody
who has this background and this
information um and I think there's also
potential positions I actually know the
first maybe not the first I know I know
someone who's actually um a commercial
Scout for cutl Farm now and that that's
not something we don't have very many
commercial Scouts for ornamentals in the
state at all so the fact that this one
cut flower farm said we need somebody
from outside we're too busy you know
we're too busy doing other things we
need somebody from outside to actually
we'll pay you to come in and Scout for
it so but yeah I do think so so good
thank you I wonder if there's
opportunities for attractive
plants um to to get to get pests attract
oh trap crops trap that's exactly my
brain yeah trap crops they are
attractive but hopefully you want them
to be attractive so radishes for flea
Beetles for is one that we actually you
can use
and the reason one reason you use
radishes is flea beetles like them
better than some of the ornamentals but
they also the seeds cheap they grow fast
you can put in a row of radishes attract
the tra attract the flea beetles and
then you need to do something there you
need to either capture them which is you
know they do actually occasionally
vacuum them um or treat them with a
pesticide on the Trap crop so that
you're not letting them go back out into
the crop yeah so yeah there is yeah do
you know what proportion of production
is perennial plants or is there like
interest in developing that for the
ecological services or mostly annuals
sticking I think there's a lot of people
who are doing both and I think people
start with annuals this is mostly
anecdotal um but then they often will
start putting in some perennials I mean
pies is a good example because peonies
are really popular they're early they're
gorgeous you know you can sell a lot of
pees um if you can grow them and so and
then the next thing that people move
into in terms of perennials is starting
putting in putting some Woodies in so
they've got them for foliage or they've
got them for large larger scale events
where you need big branches um there's
actually somebody from Cornell uh
who's a economist who's now down in
Maryland and their production is W UA
and their production is almost entirely
Woodies um and so and mostly dormant I
some dormant they do both but they'll do
yeah dormant branches as well yep so um
it is you know I think again when people
start out it's easy to start with
annuals because that's kind of the way
they've been thinking but then starting
to add in the other things and even the
concept then if you're going to put in
perennials if it's something like a pie
making sure that you have a plan for re
for renovating them or renewing them as
you go along you look like you're were
going to ask not so one of the things
that's striking is this diversity of
species and but then I was working along
side of Chris out there with the high
titles there's this whole other
component of genotype environment
interaction like he you know these
things just respond so differently same
genotype based on how they when they
were seated or what they're exposed to
whe they in a high tunnel oride High
tunnel so is there any group that's
thinking like strategically about what
our priorities and how down Focus areas
not just seems like a yeah not that I
know of and it
sometimes in term you mean in terms of
research or just in terms of
understanding that I I think both are
are not very well known and so yes so
when you're looking especially when
you're looking at repeated plantings of
things it's not the same each time even
in terms of how long it takes you to get
a flower and what the plants necessarily
look like so there's that piece from the
grower side but then there's also as far
as I can tell the research often is more
based on um like what's popular so or
what you're getting questions on so
there's lots of questions so the there
some on on lavender because lavender
lots of people want to grow lavender
it's a it's a nasty plant to gr I mean
it's if you can get if you're in a place
where you can grow it it's not a nasty
plant it's a lovely plant but it's very
picky so if you've got a place you can
grow it it's great and so again we have
people go and say well look there's just
you just put that lavender out and then
we're all set but their soil is
different and so it doesn't work so that
gets a certain amount of work done on it
but it does I don't I have not seen even
in this group that we're just kind of
getting going there's a little bit more
discussion of okay should we write a
grant together and what should be on but
overall I haven't seen much of that
saying okay let's actually look at this
these crops in enough depth to have that
information to be able to say here's
kind of
a fact sheet cookbook whatever that says
okay if you're growing this and I think
there probably are some and a lot of
them um are if they are out there
they're they're actually probably
created by Growers you know here's how
you do sequential growth of this
particular species but then you get get
different varieties and the varieties
change all the time and they don't
always necessarily act the same and
color is this big issue of so uh Carla
was doing a talk and she showed some of
the queen queen lime zenas which are
this sort of interesting combination of
pink and green and Peach and salmon and
green and chartu green and and then also
some um Lizzy anthus that are sort of
Dusty brownish pink which if you look at
in on mass look dead to me but mixed in
with with a bouquet they're very popular
they color very popular but mixed in a
bouquet I think so um and that's the
other thing is they're trying to keep up
with an annual it's easier with
perennials like how do you keep up with
what the next thing is
always there's anybody else any other
questions from Oh Thomas you have your
hand up yeah we got a question for you
it's basically how do things work around
here and for
how much the college invests or
Cooperative Extension invests in a
particular industry how that gets
decided when um you notify something or
notice a new opportunity and I think
that applies to everybody who's not in
like dairy or corn or Sobe beans um you
find I mean you've described a very
organic process where you find that
there's a need and find that there are
other people who can help in various
parts of serving that industry and then
you get some money and resources
and if it has legs it keeps
growing have you found that there's
other parts to the system that uh are
helping determine how
much um should be invested in a
new agricultural sector like this I have
not I'm not sure I've asked
um I don't know if I even know who to
ask but and and so again you know I
think sometimes it takes a little a
little bit of information gathering I
know I'm looking at your picture there
look camera a little bit of information
gathering and then putting it together
and kind of presenting it to say you
know we could use more help here or what
else can we do with this or don't you
think it'd be nice to have somebody
doing it um whether or not that will fly
at a university I don't know and then
there's also more other universities and
colleges than Cornell so someone else
may pick it up um and and run with it
too so they don't have a really good
answer for that no no but than for the
look under the
hood moving along is most of the variety
development done by like private
companies or is there a lot in like
public I would say the great majority is
at is it is at seed companies okay um
it's not that there's none anywhere else
um and then there's some that's done by
private individuals for certain cult for
certain species there's there's some
that people are actually some Cut Flower
Growers are doing themselves but also
other people that are interested are
doing I'm glad to see what Bill's not
well and some are ancient cultive Arts
you know PES some of those PES forever
right yeah we have a Cornell Mark Bri is
BR three or four
varieties I think those are the first
ornamental plants atted by cor they
could well be and now it' be interesting
to promote those to flower Growers and I
don't know whether they're if they're
aimed at Garden varieties so their stems
are not long enough they're they're long
enough they're long enough yeah Blue
Grass L were there some in Min Garden I
have no idea were some I don't know but
they're they're they're two and a half
approaching three feet and sometimes
it's it's getting the word out and like
where do people go looking for their
seed their seat usually seed but also
plugs uh and so they do don't grow it
off direct from seeding and so some of
it's like okay how do you get that
connection between the breeder the
producer and the grower and so sometimes
again you do it backwards so you get the
grower interested in get them to ask the
things
Flyers other questions thank you for the
question I always like questions more
than
talking anybody else
here thank
you
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at cornell.edu